PROFESSOR: Well, yesterday
was easy.
You learned all of the rules
of programming and lived.
Almost all of them.
And so at this point, you're
now certified programmers--
it says.
However, I suppose what we did
is we, aah, sort of got you a
little bit of into
an easy state.
Here, you still believe it's
possible that this might be
programming in BASIC or Pascal
with just a funny syntax.
Today, that illusion--
or you can no longer support
that belief.
What we're going to do
today is going to
completely smash that.
So let's start out by writing
a few programs on the
blackboard that have a lot in
common with each other.
What we're going to do is try to
make them abstractions that
are not ones that are easy to
make in most languages.
Let's start with some very
simple ones that you can make
in most languages.
Supposing I want to write the
mathematical expression which
adds up a bunch of integers.
So if I wanted to write down
and say the sum from i
equal a to b on i.
Now, you know that that's an
easy thing to compute in a
closed form for it, and I'm
not interested in that.
But I'm going to write
a program that
adds up those integers.
Well, that's rather easy to do
to say I want to define the
sum of the integers from
a to b to be--
well, it's the following
two possibilities.
If a is greater than b, well,
then there's nothing to be
done and the answer is zero.
This is how you're going to
have to think recursively.
You're going to say if I have
an easy case that I know the
answer to, just write it down.
Otherwise, I'm going to try to
reduce this problem to a
simpler problem.
And maybe in this case, I'm
going to make a subproblem of
the simpler problem and then
do something to the result.
So the easiest way to do this
is say that I'm going to add
the index, which in this case is
a, to the result of adding
up the integers from
a plus 1 to b.
Now, at this point, you should
have no trouble looking at
such a definition.
Indeed, coming up with such a
thing might be a little hard
in synthesis, but being able
to read it at this point
should be easy.
And what it says to you is,
well, here is the subproblem
I'm going to solve.
I'm going to try to add up the
integers, one fewer integer
than I added up for the
the whole problem.
I'm adding up the one fewer one,
and that subproblem, once
I've solved it, I'm going to add
a to that, and that will
be the answer to this problem.
And the simplest case, I don't
have to do any work.
Now, I'm also going to write
down another simple one just
like this, which is the
mathematical expression, the
sum of the square from
i equal a to b.
And again, it's a very
simple program.
And indeed, it starts
the same way.
If a is greater than b, then
the answer is zero.
And, of course, we're beginning
to see that there's
something wrong with me writing
this down again.
It's the same program.
It's the sum of the square of a
and the sum of the square of
the increment and b.
Now, if you look at these
things, these programs are
almost identical.
There's not much to
distinguish them.
They have the same first clause
of the conditional and
the same predicate and the
same consequence, and the
alternatives are very
similar, too.
They only differ by the fact
that where here I have a,
here, I have the square of a.
The only other difference, but
this one's sort of unessential
is in the name of this procedure
is sum int, whereas
the name of the procedure
is sum square.
So the things that vary
between these
two are very small.
Now, wherever you see yourself
writing the same thing down
more than once, there's
something wrong, and you
shouldn't be doing it.
And the reason is not because
it's a waste of time to write
something down more than once.
It's because there's some idea
here, a very simple idea,
which has to do with the
sigma notation--
this much--
not depending upon what
it is I'm adding up.
And I would like
to be able to--
always, whenever trying to make
complicated systems and
understand them, it's crucial
to divide the things up into
as many pieces as I can, each
of which I understand
separately.
I would like to understand the
way of adding things up
independently of what it is I'm
adding up so I can do that
having debugged it once and
understood it once and having
been able to share that among
many different uses of it.
Here, we have another example.
This is Leibnitz's formula
for finding pi over 8.
It's a funny, ugly mess.
What is it?
It's something like 1 over 1
times 3 plus 1 over 5 times 7
plus 1 over 9 times 11 plus--
and for some reason, things
like this tend to have
interesting values
like pi over 8.
But what do we see here?
It's the same program or almost
the same program.
It's a sum.
So we're seeing the figure
notation, although over here,
we're dealing with incrementing
by 4, so it's a
slightly different problem,
which means that over here, I
have to change a by 4, as
you see right over here.
It's not by 1.
The other thing, of course,
is that the thing that's
represented by square in the
previous sum of squares, or a
when adding up the integers.
Well, here, I have a different
thing I'm adding up, a
different term, which is 1
over a times a plus 2.
But the rest of this program
is identical.
Well, any time we have a bunch
of things like this that are
identical, we're going to have
to come up with some sort of
abstraction to cover them.
If you think about this, what
you've learned so far is the
rules of some language, some
primitive, some means of
combination, almost all
of them, the means of
abstraction, almost
all of them.
But what you haven't learned is
common patterns of usage.
Now, most of the time, you learn
idioms when learning a
language, which is a common
pattern that mean things that
are useful to know in a flash.
And if you build a great number
of them, if you're a
FORTRAN programmer, of course,
everybody knows how to--
what do you do, for example, to
get an integer which is the
biggest integer in something.
It's a classic thing.
Every FORTRAN programmer
knows how to do that.
And if you don't know that,
you're in real hot water
because it takes a long
time to think it out.
However, one of the things you
can do in this language that
we're showing you is not only
do you know something like
that, but you give the knowledge
of that a name.
And so that's what we're going
to be going after right now.
OK, well, let's see what these
things have in common.
Right over here we have what
appears to be a general
pattern, a general pattern which
covers all of the cases
we've seen so far.
There is a sum procedure,
which is being defined.
It has two arguments, which
are a lower bound
and an upper bound.
The lower bound is tested to
be greater than the upper
bound, and if it is greater,
then the result is zero.
Otherwise, we're going to do
something to the lower bound,
which is the index of the
conversation, and add that
result to the result of
following the procedure
recursively on our lower bound
incremented by some next
operation with the same upper
bound as I had before.
So this is a general pattern,
and what I'd like to do is be
able to name this general
pattern a bit.
Well, that's sort of easy,
because one of the things I'm
going to do right now is--
there's nothing very special
about numbers.
Numbers are just one
kind of data.
It seems to me perfectly
reasonable to give all sorts
of names to all kinds of data,
for example, procedures.
And now many languages allow you
have procedural arguments,
and right now, we're
going to talk
about procedural arguments.
They're very easy
to deal with.
And shortly, we'll do some
remarkable things that are not
like procedural arguments.
So here, we'll define
our sigma notation.
This is called sum and it takes
a term, an A, a next
term, and B as arguments.
So it takes four arguments,
and there was nothing
particularly special about me
writing this in lowercase.
I hope that it doesn't confuse
you, so I'll write it in
uppercase right now.
The machine doesn't care.
But these two arguments
are different.
These are not numbers.
These are going to be procedures
for computing
something given a number.
Term will be a procedure which,
when given an index,
will produce the value of
the term for that index.
Next will be given an
index, which will
produce the next index.
This will be for counting.
And it's very simple.
It's exactly what you see.
If A is greater than B,
then the result is 0.
Otherwise, it's the sum of term
applied to A and the sum
of term, next index.
Let me write it this way.
Now, I'd like you to see
something, first of all.
I was writing here, and
I ran out of space.
What I did is I start indenting
according to the
Pretty-printing rule, which says
that I align all of the
arguments of the procedure
so I can see
which ones go together.
And this is just something I do
automatically, and I want
you to learn how to do that,
too, so your programs can be
read and understood.
However, what do we have here?
We have four arguments: the
procedure, the lower index--
lower bound index--
the way to get the next index,
and the upper bound.
What's passed along on the
recursive call is indeed the
same procedure because I'm going
to need it again, the
next index, which is using the
next procedure to compute it,
the procedure for computing
next, which I also have to
have separately, and
that's different.
The procedure for computing
next is different from the
next index, which is the result
of using next on the
last index.
And I also have to pass
along the upper bound.
So this captures both of these
and the other nice program
that we are playing with.
So using this, we can write down
the original program as
instances of sum very simply.
A and B. Well, I'm going to
need an identity procedure
here because ,ahh, the sum of
the integers requires me to in
this case compute a term for
every integer, but the term
procedure doesn't want to do
anything to that integer.
So the identity procedure on A
is A or X or whatever, and I
want to say the sum of using
identity of the term procedure
and using A as the initial
index and the incrementer
being the way to get the next
index and B being the high
bound, the upper bound.
This procedure does exactly
the same as the sum of the
integers over here, computes
the same answer.
Now, one thing you should see,
of course, is that there's
nothing very special over here
about what I used as the
formal parameter.
I could have, for example,
written this
X. It doesn't matter.
I just wanted you to see that
this name does not conflict
with this one at all.
It's an internal name.
For the second procedure here,
the sum of the squares, it's
even a little bit easier.
And what do we have to do?
Nothing more than add up the
squares, this is the procedure
that each index will be given,
will be given each--
yes.
Each index will have this done
to it to get the term.
That's the thing that maps
against term over here.
Then I have A as the lower
bound, the incrementer as the
next term method, and B
as the upper bound.
And finally, just for the thing
that we did about pi
sums, pi sums are sort of--
well, it's even easier to think
about them this way
because I don't have to think.
What I'm doing is separating the
thing I'm adding up from
the method of doing
the addition.
And so we have here, for
example, pi sum A B
of the sum of things.
I'm going to write the terms
procedure here explicitly
without giving it a name.
This is done anonymously.
I don't necessarily have to give
a name to something if I
just want to use it once.
And, of course, I can write
sort of a expression that
produces a procedure.
I'm going to write the Greek
lambda letter here instead of
L-A-M-B-D-A in general to avoid
taking up a lot of space
on blackboards.
But unfortunately,
we don't have
lambda keys on our keyboards.
Maybe we can convince our
friends in the computer
industry that this
is an important.
Lambda of i is the quotient of 1
and the product of i and the
sum of i 2, starting at a with
the way of incrementing being
that procedure of an index i,
which adds i to 4, and b being
the upper bound.
So you can see that this
notation, the invention of the
procedure that takes a
procedural argument, allows us
to compress a lot of these
procedures into one thing.
This procedure, sums, covers
a whole bunch of ideas.
Now, just why is
this important?
I tried to say before that it
helps us divide a problem into
two pieces, and indeed, it does,
for example, if someone
came up with a different way of
implementing this, which,
of course, one might.
Here, for example, an iterative
implementation of sum.
Iterative implementation for
some reason might be better
than the recursive
implementation.
But the important thing is
that it's different.
Now, supposing I had written my
program this way that you
see on the blackboard
on the left.
That's correct, the left.
Well, then if I want to change
the method of addition, then
I'd have to change
each of these.
Whereas if I write them like
this that you see here, then
the method by which I did the
addition is encapsulated in
the procedure sum.
That decomposition allows me
to independently change one
part of the program and prove
it perhaps without changing
the other part that was
written for some
of the other cases.
Thank you.
Are there any questions?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Would you go over
next A and next again on--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's the same problem.
I'm sure you're going to--
you're going to have
to work on this.
This is hard the first
time you've ever seen
something like this.
What I have here is
a-- procedures
can be named by variables.
Procedures are not special.
Actually, sum square is a
variable, which has gotten a
value, which is a procedure.
This is define sum square to be
lambda of A and B something.
So the procedure can be named.
Therefore, they can be passed
from one to another, one
procedure to another,
as arguments.
Well, what we're doing here is
we're passing the procedure
term as an argument to sum just
when we get it around in
the next recursive.
Here, we're passing
the procedure next
as an argument also.
However, here we're using
the procedure next.
That's what the parentheses
mean.
We're applying next to A to get
the next value of A. If
you look at what next is mapped
against, remember that
the way you think about this
is that you substitute the
arguments for the formal
parameters in the body.
If you're ever confused, think
of the thing that way.
Well, over here, with
sum of the integers.
I substitute identity for
a term and 1 plus the
incrementer for next
in the body.
Well, the identity procedure
on A is what I get here.
Identity is being passed
along, and here, I have
increment 1 plus being applied
to A and 1 plus is being
passed along.
Does that clarify
the situation?
AUDIENCE: We could also define
explicitly those two
functions, then pass them.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
What we can do is we could have
given names to them, just
like I did here.
In fact, I gave you various
ways so you
could see it, a variety.
Here, I define the thing which
I passed the name of.
I referenced it by its name.
But the thing is, in fact, that
procedure, one argument
X, which is X. And the identity
procedure is just
lambda of X X. And that's
what you're seeing here.
Here, I happened to just write
its canonical name there for
you to see.
Is it OK if we take our
five-minute break?
As I said, computers to make
people happy, not people to
make computers happy.
And for the most part, the
reason why we introduce all
this abstraction stuff is to
make it so that programs can
be more easily written
and more easily read.
Let's try to understand what's
the most complicated program
we've seen so far using
a little bit of
this abstraction stuff.
If you look at the slide, this
is the Heron of Alexandria's
method of computing square roots
that we saw yesterday.
And let's see.
Well, in any case, this
program is a little
complicated.
And at the current state of your
thinking, you just can't
look at that and say, oh,
this obviously means
something very clear.
It's not obvious from
looking at the
program what it's computing.
There's some loop here inside
try, and a loop does something
about trying the improvement
of y.
There's something called
improve, which does some
averaging and quotienting
and things like that.
But what's the real idea?
Can we make it clear
what the idea is?
Well, I think we can.
I think we can use abstraction
that we have learned about so
far to clarify what's
going on.
Now, what we have mathematically
is a procedure
for improving a guess
for square roots.
And if y is a guess for a square
root, then what we want
to get we'll call
a function f.
This is the means
of improvement.
I want to get y plus x/y over
2, so the average of y and x
divided by y as the improved
value for the square root of x
such that-- one thing you can
notice about this function f
is that f of the square root
of f is in fact the
square root of x.
In other words, if I take
the square root of x and
substitute it for y here, I see
the square root of x plus
x divided by the square of x,
which is the square root of x.
That's 2 times the square root
of x divided by 2, is the
square root of x.
So, in fact, what we're really
looking for is we're looking
for a fixed point, a fixed
point of the function f.
A fixed point is a place which
has the property that if you
put it into the function, you
get the same value out.
Now, I suppose if I were giving
some nice, boring
lecture, and you happened to
have in front of you an HP-35
desk calculator like I
used to have when I
went to boring lectures.
And if you think it was really
boring, you put it into
radians mode, and you hit
cosine, and you hit cosine,
and you hit cosine.
And eventually, you end
up with 0.734 or
something like that.
0.743, I don't remember what
exactly, and it gets closer
and closer to that.
Some functions have the property
that you can find
their fixed point by iterating
the function, and that's
essentially what's happening in
the square root program by
Heron's method.
So let's see if we can write
that down, that idea.
Now, I'm not going to say how
I compute fixed points yet.
There might be more
than one way.
But the first thing to
do is I'm going to
say what I just said.
I'm going to say it
specifically, the square root.
The square root of x is the
fixed point of that procedure
which takes an argument
y and averages of x
divided by y with y.
And we're going to start up with
the initial guess for the
fixed point of 1.
It doesn't matter
where it starts.
A theorem having to do
with square roots.
So what you're seeing here is
I'm just trying to write out
by wishful thinking.
I don't know how I'm going to
make fixed point happen.
We'll worry about that later.
But if somehow I had a way of
finding the fixed point of the
function computed by this
procedure, then I would have--
that would be the square root
that I'm looking for.
OK, well, now let's see how
we're going to write--
how we're going to come
up with fixed points.
Well, it's very simple,
actually.
I'm going to write an
abbreviated version here just
so we understand it.
I'm going to find the fixed
point of a function f--
actually, the fixed point of the
function computed by the
procedure whose name will
be f in this procedure.
How's that?
A long sentence--
starting with a particular
starting value.
Well, I'm going to have a little
loop inside here, which
is going to push the button on
the calculator repeatedly,
hoping that it will eventually
converge.
And we will say here internal
loops are written by defining
internal procedures.
Well, one thing I'm going to
have to do is I'm going to
have to say whether I'm done.
And the way I'm going to decide
when I'm done is when
the old value and the new value
are close enough so I
can't distinguish
them anymore.
That's the standard thing you
do on the calculator unless
you look at more precision,
and eventually,
you run out of precision.
So the old value and new value,
and I'm going to stay
here if I can't distinguish them
if they're close enough,
and we'll have to worry about
what that is soon.
The old value and the new value
are close enough to each
other and let's pick the new
value as the answer.
Otherwise, I'm going to iterate
around again with the
next value of old being the
current value of new and the
next value of new being the
result of calling f on new.
And so this is my iteration loop
that pushes the button on
the calculator.
I basically think of it as
having two registers on the
calculator: old and new.
And in each step, new becomes
old, and new gets F of new.
So this is the thing where I'm
getting the next value.
And now, I'm going to
start this thing up
by giving two values.
I wrote down on the blackboard
to be slow
so you can see this.
This is the first time you've
seen something quite this
complicated, I think.
However, we might want to see
the whole thing over here in
this transparency or
slide or whatever.
What we have is all of the
details that are required to
make this thing work.
I have a way of getting a
tolerance for a close enough
procedure, which we see here.
The close enough procedure, it
tests whether u and v are
close enough by seeing if the
absolute value of the
difference in u and v is less
than the given tolerance, OK?
And here is the iteration loop
that I just wrote on the
blackboard and the
initialization for it, which
is right there.
It's very simple.
But let's see.
I haven't told you enough.
It's actually easier
than this.
There is more structure to
this problem than I've
already told you.
Like why should this work?
Why should it converge?
There's a hairy theorem in
mathematics tied up in what
I've written here.
Why is it that I should assume
that by iterating averaging
the quotient of x and y
and y that I should
get the right answer?
It isn't so obvious.
Surely there are other things,
other procedures, which
compute functions whose fixed
points would also be the
square root.
For example, the obvious one
will be a new function g,
which maps y to x/y.
That's even simpler.
The fixed point of g is surely
the square root also, and it's
a simpler procedure.
Why am I not using it?
Well, I suppose you know.
Supposing x is 2 and I start out
with 1, and if I divide 1
into 2, I get 2.
And then if I divide
2 into 2, I get 1.
If I divide 1 into 2, I get 2,
and 2 into 2, I get 1, and I
never get any closer
to the square root.
It just oscillates.
So what we have is a signal
processing system, an
electrical circuit which is
oscillating, and I want to
damp out these oscillations.
Well, I can do that.
See, what I'm really doing
here when I'm taking my
average, the average is
averaging the last two values
of something which oscillates,
getting something in between.
The classic way is damping out
oscillations in a signal
processing system.
So why don't we write down the
strategy that I just said in a
more clear way?
Well, that's easy enough.
I'm going to define the square
root of x to be a fixed point
of the procedure resulting
from average damping.
So I have a procedure resulting
from average damp of
the procedure, that procedure
of y, which divides x by y
starting out at 1.
Ah, but average damp is a
special procedure that's going
to take a procedure as its
argument and return a
procedure as its value.
It's a generalization that says
given a procedure, it's
the thing which produces a
procedure which averages the
last value and the
value before and
after running the procedure.
You can use it for anything
if you want to damp out
oscillations.
So let's write that down.
It's very easy.
And stylistically here, I'm
going to use lambda notation
because it's much easier to
think when you're dealing with
procedure, the mid-line
procedures, to understand that
the procedures are the objects
I'm dealing with, so I'm going
to use lambda notation here.
Not always.
I don't always use it, but
very specifically here to
expand on that idea,
to elucidate it.
Well, average damp is a
procedure, which takes a
procedure as its argument,
which we will call f.
And what does it produce?
It produces as its value--
the body of this procedure is
a thing which produces a
procedure, the construct of the
procedures right here, of
one argument x, which averages
f of x with x.
This is a very special thing.
I think for the first time
you're seeing a procedure
which produces a procedure
as its value.
This procedure takes the
procedure f and does something
to it to produce a new procedure
of one argument x,
which averages f--
this f--
applied to x and x itself.
Using the context here, I apply
average damping to the
procedure, which just
divides x by y.
It's a division.
And I'm finding to fixed point
of that, and that's a clearer
way of writing down what
I wrote down over
here, wherever it was.
Here, because it tells why
I am writing this down.
I suppose this to some extent
really clarifies what Heron of
Alexandria was up to.
I suppose I'll stop now.
Are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: So when you define
average damp, don't you need
to have a variable on f?
PROFESSOR: Ah, the question was,
and here we're having--
again, you've got to learn
about the syntax.
The question was when defining
average damp, don't you have
to have a variable
defined with f?
What you are asking about is
the formal parameter of f?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
The formal parameter
of f is here.
The formal parameter of f--
AUDIENCE: The formal parameter
of average damp.
PROFESSOR: F is being
used to apply it to
an argument, right?
It's indeed true that f must
have a formal parameter.
Let's find out what f's
formal parameter is.
AUDIENCE: The formal parameter
of average damp.
PROFESSOR: Oh, f is the formal
parameter of average damp.
I'm sorry.
You're just confusing
a syntactic thing.
I could have written
this the other way.
Actually, I didn't understand
your question.
Of course, I could have written
it this other way.
Those are identical notations.
This is a different way
of writing this.
You're going to have to get
used to lambda notation
because I'm going to use it.
What it says here, I'm defining
the name average damp
to name the procedure whose
of one argument f.
That's the formal parameter of
the procedure average damp.
What define does is it says
give this name a value.
Here is the value of for it.
That there happens to be a
funny syntax to make that
easier in some cases is
purely convenience.
But the reason why I wrote it
this way here is to emphasize
that I'm dealing with a
procedure that takes a
procedure as its argument
and produces a
procedure as its value.
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
why you use lambda twice.
Can you just use one
lambda and take two
arguments f and x?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: You can't?
PROFESSOR: No, that would
be a different thing.
If I were to write the procedure
lambda of f and x,
the average of f of x and x,
that would not be something
which would be allowed to take a
procedure as an argument and
produce a procedure
as its value.
That would be a thing that
takes a procedure as its
argument and numbers
its argument and
produces a new number.
But what I'm producing here is
a procedure to fit in the
procedure slot over here,
which is going to
be used over here.
So the number has to
come from here.
This is the thing that's going
to eventually end up in the x.
And if you're confused, you
should do some substitution
and see for yourself.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Will you please show
the definition for average
damp without using lambda
notation in both cases.
PROFESSOR: I can't make a very
simple one like that.
Let me do it for you, though.
I can get rid of this
lambda easily.
I don't want to be--
actually, I'm lying to you.
I don't want to do what you want
because I think it's more
confusing than you think.
I'm not going to write
what you want.
So we'll have to get a name.
FOO of x to be of F of x and x
and return as a value FOO.
This is equivalent, but
I've had to make an
arbitrary name up.
This is equivalent to this
without any lambdas.
Lambda is very convenient for
naming anonymous procedures.
It's the anonymous name
of something.
Now, if you really want to know
a cute way of doing this,
we'll talk about it later.
We're going to have to define
the anonymous procedure.
Any other questions?
And so we go for our
break again.
So now we've seen how
to use high-order
procedures, they're called.
That's procedures that take
procedural arguments and
produce procedural values to
help us clarify and abstract
some otherwise complicated
processes.
I suppose what I'd like to do
now is have a bit of fun with
that and sort of a little
practice as well.
So let's play with this square
root thing even more.
Let's elaborate it and
understand what's going on and
make use of this kind of
programming style.
One thing that you might know
is that there is a general
method called Newton's method
the purpose of which is to
find the roots--
that's the zeroes--
of functions.
So, for example, to find a y
such that f of y equals 0, we
start with some guess.
This is Newton's method.
And the guess we start with
we'll call y0, and then we
will iterate the following
expression.
y n plus 1-- this is a
difference equation--
is yn minus f of yn over the
derivative with respect to y
of f evaluated at y equal yn.
Very strange notation.
I must say ugh.
The derivative of f with respect
to y is a function.
I'm having a little bit of
unhappiness with that, but
that's all right.
It turns out in the programming
language world,
the notation is much clearer.
Now, what is this?
People call it Newton's
method.
It's a method for finding the
roots of the function f.
And it, of course, sometimes
converges, and when it does,
it does so very fast. And
sometimes, it doesn't
converge, and, oh well, we have
to do something else.
But let's talk about square
root by Newton's method.
Well, that's rather
interesting.
Let's do exactly the same thing
we did last time: a bit
of wishful thinking.
We will apply Newton's method,
assuming we knew how to do it.
You don't know how
to do it yet.
Well, let's go.
What do I have here?
The square root of x.
It's Newton's method applied
to a procedure which will
represent that function
of y, which computes
that function of y.
Well, that procedure is that
procedure of y, which is the
difference between x and
the square of y.
Indeed, if I had a value of y
for which this was zero, then
y would be the square
root of x.
See that?
OK, I'm going to start this
out searching at 1.
Again, completely arbitrary
property of square roots that
I can do that.
Now, how am I going to compute
Newton's method?
Well, this is the method.
I have it right here.
In fact, what I'm doing is
looking for a fixed point of
some procedure.
This procedure involves some
complicated expressions in
terms of other complicated
things.
Well, I'm trying to find the
fixed point of this.
I want to find the values of y,
which if I put y in here, I
get the same value out here up
to some degree of accuracy.
Well, I already have a
fixed point process
around to do that.
And so, let's just define
Newton's method over here.
A procedure which computes
a function and a
guess, initial guess.
Now, I'm going to have
to do something here.
I'm going to need the derivative
of the function.
I'm going to need a procedure
which computes the derivative
of the function computed by
the given a procedure f.
I'm trying to be very careful
about what I'm saying.
I don't want to mix up the word
procedure and function.
Function is a mathematical
word.
It says I'm mapping from values
to other values, a set
of ordered pairs.
But sometimes, I'll accidentally
mix those up.
Procedures compute functions.
So I'm going to define the
derivative of f to be by
wishful thinking again.
I don't know how I'm
going to do it.
Let's worry about that later--
of F. So if F is a procedure,
which happens to be this one
over here for a square root,
then DF will be the derivative
of it, which is also the
derivative of the function
computed by that procedure.
DF will be a procedure that
computes the derivative of the
function computed by the
procedure F. And then given
that, I will just go looking
for a fixed point.
What is the fixed point
I'm looking for?
It's the one for that procedure
of one argument x,
which I compute by
subtracting x.
That's the old-- that's
the yn here.
The quotient of f of x and df
of x, starting out with the
original guess.
That's all very simple.
Now, I have one part left that
I haven't written, and I want
you to see the process by which
I write these things,
because this is really true.
I start out with some
mathematical idea, perhaps.
By wishful thinking, I assume
that by some magic I can do
something that I have
a name for.
I'm not going to worry about
how I do it yet.
Then I go walking down here and
say, well, by some magic,
I'm somehow going to figure how
to do that, but I'm going
to write my program anyway.
Wishful thinking, essential
to good engineering, and
certainly essential to a
good computer science.
So anyway, how many of
you wished that your
computer ran faster?
Well, the derivative isn't
so bad either.
Sort of like average damping.
The derivative is a procedure
that takes a procedure that
computes a function as its
argument, and it produces a
procedure that computes a
function, which needs one
argument x.
Well, you all know
this definition.
It's f of x plus delta x minus
f of x over delta x, right?
For some small delta x.
So that's the quotient of the
difference of f of the sum of
x and dx minus f point
x divided by dx.
I think the thing was lining up
correctly when I balanced
the parentheses.
Now, I want you to
look at this.
Just look.
I suppose I haven't told
you what dx is.
Somewhere in the world I'm going
to have to write down
something like that.
I'm not interested.
This is a procedure which takes
a procedure and produces
an approximation, a procedure
that computes an approximation
of the derivative of the
function computed by the
procedure given by the standard
methods that you all
know and love.
Now, it may not be the case that
doing this operation is
such a good way of approximating
a derivative.
Numerical analysts here
should jump on me and
say don't do that.
Computing derivatives produces
noisy answers, which is true.
However, this again is for the
sake of understanding.
Look what we've got.
We started out with what is
apparently a mathematically
complex thing.
and.
In a few blackboards full, we
managed to decompose the
problem of computing square
roots by the way you were
taught in your college
calculus class--
Newton's method--
so that it can be understood.
It's clear.
Let's look at the structure
of what it is we've got.
Let's look at this slide.
This is a diagram of the machine
described by the
program on the blackboard.
There's a machine
described here.
And what have I got?
Over here is the Newton's method
function f that we have
on the left-most blackboard.
It's the thing that takes an
argument called y and puts out
the difference between x and
the square of y, where x is
some sort of free variable that
comes in from the outside
by some magic.
So the square root routine picks
up an x, and builds this
procedure, which I have the
x rolled up in it by
substitution.
Now, this procedure in the cloud
is fed in as the f into
the Newton's method which
is here, this box.
The f is fanned out.
Part of it goes into something
else, and the other part of it
goes through a derivative
process into something else to
produce a procedure, which
computes the function which is
the iteration function of
Newton's method when we use
the fixed point method.
So this procedure, which
contains it by substitution--
remember, Newton's method over
here, Newton's method builds
this procedure, and Newton's
method has in it defined f and
df, so those are captured
over here: f and df.
Starting with this procedure,
I can now feed this to the
fixed point process within an
initial guess coming out from
the outside from square
root to produce the
square root of x.
So what we've built is a very
powerful engine, which allows
us to make nice things
like this.
Now, I want to end this with
basically an idea of Chris
Strachey, one of the
grandfathers of computer science.
He's a logician who
lived in the--
I suppose about 10 years ago
or 15 years ago, he died.
I don't remember exactly when.
He's one of the inventors
of something called
denotational semantics.
He was a great advocate of
making procedures or functions
first-class citizens in a
programming language.
So here's the rights and
privileges of first-class
citizens in a programming
language.
It allows you to make any
abstraction you like if you
have functions as first-class
citizens.
The first-class citizens
must be able
to be named by variables.
And you're seeing me doing
that all the time.
Here's a nice variable which
names a procedure which
computes something.
They have to be passed as
arguments to procedures.
We've certainly seen that.
We have to be able to return
them as values from
procedures.
And I suppose we've seen that.
We haven't yet seen anything
about data structures.
We will soon, but it's also the
case that in order to have
a first-class citizen in a
programming language, the
object has to be allowed to be
part of a data structure.
We're going to see that soon.
So I just want to close with
this and say having things
like procedures as first-class
data structures, first-class
data, allows one to make
powerful abstractions, which
encode general methods
like Newton's method
in very clear way.
Are there any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you put
derivative instead of df
directly in the fixed point?
PROFESSOR: Oh, sure.
Yes, I could have put deriv of
f right here, no question.
Any time you see something
defined, you can put the thing
that the definition is
there because you
get the same result.
In fact, what that would look
like, it's interesting.
AUDIENCE: Lambda.
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: You could put the
lambda expression in there.
PROFESSOR: I could also put
derivative of f here.
It would look interesting
because of the open paren,
open paren, deriv of f,
closed paren on an x.
Now, that would have the bad
property of computing the
derivative many times, because
every time I would run this
procedure, I would compute
the derivative again.
However, the two open parens
here both would be meaningful.
I want you to understand
syntactically that that's a
sensible thing.
Because if was to rewrite this
program-- and I should do it
right here just so
you see because
that's a good question--
of F and guess to be fixed point
of that procedure of one
argument x, which subtracts
from x the quotient of F
applied to x and the deriv
of F applied to x.
This is guess.
This is a perfectly legitimate
program,
because what I have here--
remember the evaluation rule.
The evaluation rule is evaluate
all of the parts of
the combination: the operator
and the operands.
This is the operator of
this combination.
Evaluating this operator will,
of course, produce the
derivative of F.
AUDIENCE: To get it one step
further, you could put the
lambda expression there, too.
PROFESSOR: Oh, of course.
Any time I take something which
is define, I can put the
thing it's defined to be in
the place where the thing
defined is.
I can't remember which is
definiens and which is
definiendum.
When I'm trying to figure out
how to do a lecture about this
in a freshman class, I use such
words and tell everybody
it's fun to tell
their friends.
OK, I think that's it.